John is with us Jonathan Kalamazoo
Michigan hey John how are you I'm doing
good and are you better than I deserve
what's up hey I just read Total Money
Makeover and just started listening your
show so I have a question about how I
should spend my tax return and a little
bit of a bonus of work I'm getting sure
in relation to my debt snowball I have a
total of about $24,000 in debt ten
Evette is a vehicle loan nine of it is a
loan from my retirement for a house and
then 5,000 of that is credit card debt
I'm guessing that the total between the
tax return and the bonus is going to be
between ten and twelve thousand dollars
and that question was would it be okay
just to pay the car off because that's
where I'm spending a majority that's
where the highest payments are would it
be okay to pay that off first
and then start at the bottom of my
snowball yeah how much debt have you
paid off so far since I just started
reading the book oh so you haven't paid
off anything okay I love the day that I
read the book I sold another vehicle
that I had we actually had two vehicles
sold that and paid it off because we
didn't need it and then I paid off one
other credit card which is like $700
good okay so you're already started
actually taking action that's good oh
yeah right away as soon as they ready
what is your what's your household
income just over one hundred thousand a
year
little 104 all right so let's say we use
these to the bonus and the tax return
and paid off the car and you'll have a
little left then you throw that at the
credit cards and then how fast would you
pay off the rest of the credit cards if
I if I sold the car you're saying well
that would free up three hundred twenty
five extra dollars a month towards the
five thousand dollars in credit card
debt so I mean I can get rid of that in
about six to eight months I'm thinking
six months okay it's way too slow with
the common money make and you squeeze
more money out of your budget I'm
thinking I need to be paying
you know a couple thousand dollars a
month towards debt here okay and if you
did that then let's pretend you got
twelve in your hand and you paid off the
car for ten that and threw two at the
credit cards and then you're paying two
thousand dollars a month off you're
gonna pay the credit cards off in about
two more months that's that's right
agile I would have you on okay okay
or if we reverse it and do it my way
which is pay off the smallest debt with
now of all the credit cards and we throw
the that's five thousand and then we
throw the other seven at the car
that means the cars only got three
thousand left on it and it's paid off in
two months right which is what I would
do
okay I'll chop up all the credit cards
today if they haven't chopped up already
done good good and I'm not gonna as soon
as the money comes in and pay them off
and then I'd pay the rest of it on the
car as fast and as furiously as I can
from my squeezed down every dollar
budget and from any other bonus money I
can get my hands on from anywhere every
day have a garage sell everything and I
think that from the time the tax return
and the bonus money comes to you from
that time forward within two to three
months you'll be debt-free everything
except the 401 k loan and then you'll
have to save up and pay it off in one
fell swoop if they won't let you pay
extra on it except at one time and so
you'll just continue to pay your
minimums on it until you build up and up
in savings to write a check and pay it
off at once and that's of what I would
do there so a good question hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]